[Musique]
et
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau vip
aujourd'hui nous sommes à versailles à
la pâtisserie fine avec vous sébastien
serveau bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
chocolatiers et pâtissiers reconnu vous
avez voir votre première boutique
personnelle finances de décembre 2020
pourquoi avoir fait ce choix maintenant
ça fait déjà un petit moment que j'avais
envie d'ouvrir ma pâtisserie
chocolaterie et
et du coup j'avais ma société de
consulting je me déplaçais beaucoup dans
le monde entier et le fait de me poser
quelque part était vraiment une priorité
était devenu priorité avec le temps donc
on est ici à versailles vous habitez à
montigny c'est important pour vous
d'être dans les yvelines
oui c'est vrai que
moi j'avais pas très loin de versailles
et versa ici une pique qui correspondait
vraiment à oscille de pâtisseries que
j'avais et avec mon époux c'est vrai
qu'on versailles nous a toujours plus on
vient souvent marché et ont trouvé qu'il
avait pas une pâtisserie
même si ce qu'ils avaient sur versailles
est très bien mais on n'avait pas une
pâtisserie haut de gamme donc du coup
bah c'était tout naturel qu'on a
vraiment voulu s'installer à versailles
ici vous avez une clientèle qui apprécie
votre pâtisserie qui est aux gains du
coup oui oui tout à fait les gens
apprécient la qualité des produits les
matières premières ils sont réceptifs
justement au visuel et
et au bout de ce qu'on peut fabriquer au
quotidien donc de travailler avec des
producteurs locaux des producteurs du
coin ça c'est important dans le produit
final ça a son importance tout à fait
parce que ce moment déjà ça fait
travailler les gens aussi de la région
et puis on met en avant des produits à
travers nos pâtisseries et ça les
clients sont très réceptifs et donc vous
travaillez aussi des produits du monde
qui ont leur importance à ce niveau là
la vanille madagascar voilà la vanille
de madagascar de tahiti les noisettes de
piedmont donc cesser les produits que je
suis emporté de très bonne qualité
également
et on retrouve vraiment le produit même
si les transformer vraiment c'est comme
vous fermez les yeux vous l'avez
directement devant les yeux quoi faire
c'est très important
et question qu'est ce qui vous plaît
dans la pâtisserie qu'est ce que vous
voulez mettre en avant c'est le goût le
visuel la texture mais je dirais que le
visuel est très important parce que
c'est ce qui va faire arrêter quelqu'un
devant nos vitrines mais le goût va
faire revenir le client donc le visuel
et le goût pour moi
sont pas dissociables il doit vraiment
aller ça doit fonctionner ensemble et
et après voilà on fidélise les gens
parce qu' il aime le visuel et le goût
leur plaît donc ça c'est primordial pour
moi c'est un touché mais ici la texture
de jouer avec les textures du croquant
tout à fait j'ai pas de gâteau il ya que
du moelleux
mis à part le baba au rhum mais sinon il
ya toujours une texture de biscuits de
mousse de croustillant de crémone les
choses qui font voyager à travers un
travers le gâteau à travers les
différentes de différents étages qui
composent le gâteau est alors vous vous
passionnez pour le sucre d'art pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas c'est quoi le
sycot d'art alors le sucre d'art en fait
j'ai fait beaucoup de concours jusqu'au
concours de meilleur ouvrier de france
où j'étais le plus jeune finaliste en
2000 en 2004 pardon et
et donc c'est
une masse de caramel qui est coloré
qu'on travaille sous une lampe qui
chauffe et on fait des fleurs ont fait
des rubans ont fait des pièces
artistiques mais c'est un petit peu
similaire aux souffleurs de verre au
métier de souffleur de verre
d'ailleurs ça a été une source
d'inspiration pour moi lorsque je
faisais des concours maintenant j'en
fais un petit peu moins mais dès qu'on
va avoir un petit peu plus de temps on
va on fera des petites pièces montées et
des pièces en sucre pour maître dans
l'art dans la boutique ça plaît toujours
aux gens là on a fait une pièce en
chocolat
les gens s'y arrêtent ils prennent en
photo donc on va faire la même chose
avec le sucre bientôt donc ça permet
d'avoir des formes en fait que vous
retrouvez pas forcément avec le d'autres
produits c'est ça oui tout à fait vrai
et donc avant d'ouvrir cette boutique
vous avez été chef dans de grandes
maisons
vous avez notamment pris en charge en
2005 de pôle formation et conseil en
pâtisserie chez alain ducasse
oui vous avez aussi que plusieurs livres
de pâtisseries c'est important de
transmettre votre savoir
oui moi ça a toujours été un plaisir de
partager soit des choses qu'on m'avait
transmis soit et les créations lorsque
je faisais concours où je faisais des
recherches j'ai essayé de faire des
choses et du coup dès que je trouver
quelque chose j'aime et le transmettre
donc d'avoir des apprentis d'avoir des
stagiaires
et notamment mon métier de consultant où
j'ai fait plusieurs fois le tour du
monde voilà la transmission ça c'est
vraiment très important pour moi et ça
fait aussi avancer le métier ce que
j'avais à vous dire la pâtisserie la
restauration c'est un métier de
transmission avant tout brillé tout à
fait parce que sinon on stagne et ont
fait pas évoluer le métier donc c'est
important
moi en tout cas je garde pas les
recettes pour moi dès que je fais
quelque chose je transmets tout de suite
ici vous avez des apprentis oui voilà
j'avais deux apprentis j'ai des
stagiaires donc les
tout le monde y trouve son compte et ils
sont très très content d'apprendre au
quotidien ici puis moi je suis là tout
le temps donc du coup je suis vraiment
là pour eux quand ils en ont besoin et
donc dans les autres maisons vous étiez
notamment chef pâtissier de l'hôtel
avait disparue puis chef exécutif de la
pâtisserie chocolaterie de la maison de
l'ado dalloyau pardo qu'est ce que vous
avez appris de fondamental chaque maison
a eu
un impact différent le
l'hôtel ritz était vraiment vraiment un
très bel hôtel un très grand hôtel et
pouvoir y rentrer c'était c'était pas
facile mais d'y être c'était vraiment un
aboutissement et après la maison
dalloyau c'était surtout le management
parce que j'avais 70 pâtissier j'avais
60 pâtissier d'un chocolatier a
supervisé donc au niveau organisation
management c'était assez assez compliqué
mais ça m'a vraiment beaucoup plus donc
ça a été une autre facette de mon métier
et du coup toutes ses facettes là on les
retrouve en fait dans mon entreprise
maintenant qu'on a qu'on a fondé avec
mon épouse c'est là bas aussi vous avez
appris le lot diane oui alors appris le
haut de gamme non parce que j'ai depuis
tout jeune j'ai toujours voulu faire du
haut de gamme
j'avais deux objectifs c'était faire de
grandes maisons sur paris arrivant de
province et le deuxième objectif c'était
d'arriver au concours de meilleur
ouvrier de france donc on est sur du
haut de gamme aussi donc je dirais pas
que j'ai appris le haut de gamme j'avais
vraiment ça en moi je voulais vraiment
faire des maisons pour découvrir mais
pour aussi continuer dans l'esprit que
je m'étais fixé au tout début du métier
et ce concours du coup du meilleur
ouvrier de france et qu'est ce qui vous
en regardez aujourd'hui c'était une
belle expérience après j'ai eues j'étais
pas suffisamment prêt j'ai cassé ma
pièce du coup c'était un petit peu
compliqué mais mais ça reste une belle
expérience
maintenant je
j'ai coaché deux candidats qu'ils ont eu
aussi donc du coup ça me fait un petit
peu faire le concours à travers d'autres
personnes ça a été une belle expérience
aussi de et de candidats et de coaching
et on est toujours dans la transmission
du coup alors exactement et donc vous
votre pâtisserie préférée pas pour
fabriquer mais pour déguster c'est quoi
alors moi c'est le mont blanc j'ai
vraiment retravailler le mont-blanc
revisité en gardant bien sûr les trois
éléments qui est la meringue la
chantilly la crème de marrons mais pour
le moderniser au niveau visuel qu'ils
soient qu'ils fassent un peu moins lourd
visuellement et que les textures aussi
soit plus légère donc c'est vraiment
devenu un incontournable ici dans notre
boutique s'est le plus vendu est le 2ème
gérer c'est la tarte citron meringuée
qui est aussi un élément phare de notre
maison
si vous aujourd'hui vous avez envie
d'une pâtisserie vous prendriez un
montblanc ou une tarte citron meringuée
oui voilà c'est après il ya aussi le
millefeuille à les éclaire enfin moi je
conteste une pâtisserie
quand je suis en déplacement c'est
toujours un classique et un moderne
j'aime bien j'aime bien tester les deux
mais c'est vrai que classiers que les
fondamentaux les basses et c'est le
ciment de notre métier c'est très
important de bien les maîtriser pour
après va pouvoir développer de la
modernité les choses un peu plus élaboré
et la pâtisserie que vous avez aimé le
plus travaillé que vous vous êtes le
plus fier aujourd'hui c'est quoi la
tarte citron meringuée c'est vrai que
j'ai beaucoup travaillé cet été sur
cette forme
de tarte sur toutes les textures et
notamment la meringue la plupart du
temps on trouve une meringue qui est
brûlée au chalumeau qui est pas cuites
la meringue en fait de ma tarte est
passé au four donc ma tarte entière il
passé au four à cameron dessus ce qui
fait que les sucres et deux fois en
surface la meringue elle-même est un peu
moins sucré mais ça vous permet d'avoir
une croûte
au dessus qui est très craquante et à
l'intérieur une meringue très moelleuse
donc c'est ce jeux de textures que les
gens apprécient énormément
et puis je fais une marmelade de citron
je fais des citrons confits donc tout
est fait maison vraiment et
rien est acheté tout fait quoi donc ça
va les gens l'ont bien compris
ça donne envie et donc vous êtes aussi
consultant international donc vous aider
d'autres confrères à renouveler leur
carte manager etc
comment vous trouvez votre inspiration à
la fois pour vous et pour les autres
mais pour moi c'est c'est bien parce que
en fait justement toutes ces expériences
de déplacement c'est aussi des échanges
on apprend aux autres mais on apprend
aussi beaucoup soi-même notamment sur
des produits ou des façons de faire on
voit là s'il est toujours une source
d'inspiration et puis c'est une façon de
vivre aussi qui est différente
il ya des produits qu'on découvre à
l'étranger qui sont très intéressants
qui me permet un petit peu après de
rentrer chez moi de lire travailler à
mon goût en essayant de toucher le
maximum de personnes
alors que quand on transmet à l'étranger
on a vraiment une ligne directive de la
part du client qui dit voilà moi ce que
j'aimerais ce que je veux ce que je veux
pas et là du coup on est obligé de
travailler par rapport à ce que souhaite
le client que ce soit des produits que
ce soit de matériel
les conditions humaines aussi de fonds
n'a pas beaucoup de monde donc il faut
trouver des montages des choses qui soit
rapide à faire il faut vraiment
s'adapter au maximum la demande du
client alors que la moelle et
contraintes pour mon entreprise je les
connais donc je sais tout de suite là ou
là où je veux aller
est ce qu'il y ait des produits vous
n'avez pas libre l'habitude d'utiliser
par exemple vous avez pu découvrir et
finalement ça a super bien fonctionné le
poids de timides par exemple en chine
j'ai utilisé pour la première fois il ya
quelques années et je savais pas
franchement quoi faire avec le poids du
team huttes et
j'ai marié ça j'ai fait un macaron
pamplemousse tu imites cas vraiment bien
marché et donc j'étais très content donc
je pense qu'un jour prochain il sera
dans la gamme
chez moi aussi et donc pour pâques
c'est bientôt qu'est ce que vous avez
prévu ici est ce que vous restez sur des
classiques
est ce que vous prenez des classiques
revisités alors pas qu'on a fait bien
sûr la gamme de chocolats incontournable
et on a fait un gros oeuf de pâques ont
appelé le joyau avec bien sûr garni
avec de la friture des petits oeufs
pralinés et par contre on a fait aussi
un petit gâteau dans le même esprit le
même visuel autour du chocolat au lait
avec une note cacaotées c'est à dire que
je mélange du chocolat au lait avec un
petit peu de chocolat noir pour pas
avoir trop de sucre et jouer sur les
textures un biscuit cacao un
croustillant au crumble au cacao un
crémeux chocolat au lait ou chocolat au
lait voilà tout autour de la gourmandise
pour que ça plaise aux petits et aux
grands
il ya aussi des petits lapins j'imagine
oui voilà il ya un petit lapin fenêtre
qui est notre super héros donc ça ça
plaît beaucoup aux enfants
et puis après on est plus en classique
sur les cloches les oeufs les poules les
ja voilà tout ce qui les touche un petit
peu toute la famille minimaliste mais
avec beaucoup de bouffe
oui voilà on essaye vraiment de jouer
sur la qualité du fait du chocolat
évidemment et puis de pas pour la
première année en tout cas on n'a pas
fait une montage trop long à mon affaire
à réaliser donc si on y réfléchira pour
l'année prochaine on a voulu aller à
l'essentiel et surtout toujours le
produit le produit en priorité et
donc là vous venez d'ouvrir votre
boutique ça fait quelques mois qu'est ce
que vous avez prévu pour la suite une
autre boutique la suite oui ce serait un
deuxième point de vente effectivement
c'est vrai que la première
en tout cas celle ci fonctionne vraiment
bien on pensait pas qu'on aurait un
accueil aussi chaleureux dé versailles
et mêmes les alentours
si on a des gens qui viennent de paris
il ya des gens qui viennent de villes
aux alentours donc quand on a entendu
parler le bouche à oreille a vraiment
bien fonctionné aussi et donc on se dit
que
envisageant deuxième point de vente sur
2022 pourquoi pas adversaires peut-être
à versailles
on verra l'avenir nous dira merci
beaucoup sébastien serveau merci et
merci à vous d'avoir suivi cette
émission se retrouve bientôt dans un
nouveau vive
[Musique]